et maintenant
m
voici nos hivers tignac
louis bertignac
non
soulac alors
ça va impec
alors vous revenez avec un cd dvd
intitulé longtemps mais c'est vrai qu'on
l'a attendu longtemps ce troisième album
solo louis bertignac il ya neuf ans que
96 est sorti pour être logique
en 98 c'était un live voilà alors ceci
étant cette période a été riche en
événements pour vous d'abord vous êtes
tombé amoureux ouais d'une dénommée
julie de la fosse qui est bien mignonne
qui comédienne et qui vous a été
présenté par etienne roda-gil un peu
comme romane serda a été présenté à
renault par étienne roda-gil et je me
rends compte qu'ils tiennent finalement
je crois qu'il était parolier et cinéma
dame de sachets voilà marieur en fait un
c'est lui qui me l'a présenté oui il la
connaissait il avait trouvé très
mignonne il traînait voilà l est et
barmen beaucoup il avait rencontré voilà
et donc vous allez rencontrer cet cet
amour je crois qu'on peut dire non plus
tout à fait fin mot et vous avez une
petite fille qui s'appelle lola callikan
mois et donc vous êtes fou oui c'est le
mot aussi un défi sionnel là aussi un
c'est un peu comme renault et les romane
serda si vous êtes tous les trois nous
là aussi à tous les trois l'un sur
l'autre ou et tous les toits l'un sur
l'autre toute la journée
autant qu'on poway ouais c'est à dire
que faire un enfant à 50 ans ça c'est un
bon côté oui on a le temps de d'ampera
page et on va je vis très bien
alors donc après la tournée 98 vous êtes
entré en studio avec des musiciens c'est
là que vous avez fait les bouches de
longtemps beaucoup de morceaux qu'il m'a
mal de morceaux gens là voilà et puis
c'est là que vous décidez de faire un
check up et vous découvrez que vous avez
une hépatite c vous décidez de vous
soigner mais au népal je me suis soigné
jeu
et je me suis dit bon c'est on m'avait
prévenu que c'était un traitement un peu
lourd un peu fatiguant donc je me suis
dit bon tant qu'à faire autant que la
vie soit un peu plus agréable qu'à paris
donc j'étais au népal parce que c'est un
endroit que j'aime bien au moins changer
d'atmosphère vous dites quoi ouais et
alors le traitement c'est épouvantable
non alors c'est dur déjà douze heures
d'avion à cette époque vous flippez
énormément parce que vous vous dites
j'ai un look vous étiez fatigué vous
étiez malade quoi vous étiez voyage on
se sent un peu comme merci on se sent
comme à 85 ans je suppose que c'est un
poste effet on peut pas ma remontée à
monter un étage ça prend 10 minutes
1 et comme la fille a déjà vingt ans de
moins oui c'était une de mes grandes
angoisses et est que bon déjà vingt ans
de moins est très mignonne je me disais
c'est s était déjà une grosse grosse
aubaine que je là que je lui plaisent
mais malade ça commençait à faire
beaucoup
batel vouloir rester avec moi et elle
reste malgré la maladie là vous vous
dites c'est la bonne voilà ça a aidé
aussi voilà elle restée là vous décidé
de prendre les choses calmement vous dit
de laisser le speed deux côtés quoi d'un
seul coup est ce que c'est la maladie
qui vous a amené à prendre tout ça sur
un autre rythme entre l'amour la maladie
wesh
et puis je parle les gens que je
rencontre et qui qui change un peu mais
je pense que c'est surtout la maladie
qui m'a qui m'a fait me dire arrête de
courir après quelque chose toute ta vie
profites tu aurais pu crever d'armes en
profite c'est du bonus maintenant ouais
c'est a donné beaucoup de poids ou aux
années qui restent quoi je crois bien
enfin eu plus de plaisir - de moins de
tension je crois en la vous produisez
l'album de corinne autre ex téléphone et
vous produisez surtout l'album de carla
bruni qui était un succès considérable
oui
je me sens quand quelqu'un climatique
que tu me lance-t-il
alors carla bruni vous là vous l'aviez
connu quand elle avait 16 ans et vous 30
ya toujours une différence d'âge 1 chez
vous quand même je suis jeune dans la
tête alors il faut que je rencontre des
jeunes
je crois qu'il ya un truc comme ça ça où
je mets mes copains même mes copains
sont plus jeunes que moi et alors elle
était fan de téléphone en fait c'est ça
c'est une groupie qu'est venu vous voir
cette musique quoi vous êtes resté
combien de temps ensemble la première
fois au nom un an à peu près mois après
elle a été très connu il y avait ces
affiches partout et a été vivre à new
york bon donc j'ai suivi de plus loin et
vous êtes retrouvé donc pour faire sens
pour faire son album when et après on
est resté potes et un jour elle
m'appelle en me disant écoute j'ai
besoin que tu me donnes des conseils je
m'en sors pas alors j'ai écouté et je
dis ouais je pense que ça devrait être
plutôt comme si je fais écouter ce que
je pensais elle m'a dit c'est toi qui me
faut et alors ce qui est formidable
c'est que dont vous avez fait ce succès
énorme ensemble et elle a continué à
travailler avec vous sur l'album que
vous sortiez aujourd'hui longtemps et
donc celle qui a fait les paroles de la
chanson qu'on va écouter
jours
m
la musique bertignac parole carla bruni
du comice orlando orlando vous
connaissiez allons nous oui c'est pas le
frère de dalida orlando non non j'ai
entendu parler à dalida ouais voilà un
frère ah ouais et orlando exige le clip
ils exigent le clip à chaque fois qu'un
chanteur il exige le client landau bain
rouge et un clip mais c'est moi qui les
fais à la maison c'est pas un as mais il
veut qu'on le voit on peut le voir si
vous êtes mais il faut que vous regardez
votre caméra en disant magnéto serge
c'est tout et où malawi magnéto serge